Her low freak bitches.
Here's what I realized.
It's like bring this back home to base.
Here's what I realized during sober October,
October,
I don't need alcohol,
but I like it.
It's great.
Yeah,
it's great.
It is fine.
Great.
No need weed.
But I like it.
Yeah.
I liked him.
I like it.
Kitten.
It's for me it's changed how my circuitry works,
you know?
It's changed how I like,
uh,
how I communicate with people and I think that there's,
the thing about alcohol is like you pay for it.
Yeah,
you definitely pay for it physically,
but you,
there's like an exchange to things to figure out what that exchange is like,
what's it,
what's it worth getting really lit and having an amazing time and hugging your
friends,
telling him you love him and just how that,
and let,
let me tell you something.
I think to this day about one of the Times you and I got drunk together in
Texas,
we first started going on the road together.
We would go on the road together for like a couple of years and we were in like
a honky tonk bar.
I remember that was a Houston or Austin,
I feel,
I don't know why I think of,
I thought it was Louisville or something,
somewhere in Texas and we were hammered and were just hugging Wah.
I'm like,
dude,
I have so much fun.
And you said the same thing.
And like we could say things that you always knew that I uh,
appreciate you as a comedian and you always knew that we were friendly and we
had some gates together but it took us getting drunk to like hug it out.
Go do it.
We're having so much fun.
Like pretty sure I cried.
Yeah,
you definitely cried.
So that's not like I didn't want to bring,
I'm crying.
I'm crying right now.
I really am crying right now cause it's like,
cause I knew you were,
you're a good dude,
man.
You were funny as fuck.
And I,
and I knew what you were because I had been where you were.
You were,
you were at the launching pad.
Like God damn is this happening?
Like what's happening?
I do am my fucked.
Is it going to work out?
You know,
there's that weird moment.
And you know,
and I had already been there before and we were friends and I was like,
dude,
you got to,
you is going to work,
you're going to do it 100% and then we were drunk together and we're talking
about that moment.
I think about that all the time,
man.
I really do.
I do now when you're killing it,
I think about,
I'm crying.
I think about that shit all the time.
I do you know to see someone that you like when I met you in like 2007 I mean
you would obviously like been doing comedy a couple of years but you were,
you were trying to figure it out,
you know.
Well I think about,
I think about it too cause like,
you know,
it's hard like people don't realize the opportunity when when you,
when you kind of reached down and you bring somebody along for that,
it's hard sometimes to convey like your gratitude,
you know?
So like that was one of those times where like in soap when you're sober you go
like do thanks so much.
Like how many times you're going to say,
you know what I mean,
like you go,
I really appreciate it.
But when that's,
that goes back to like what the alcohol kind of opens up for you is like you let
down your guard,
you let down that you let the vulnerability come to the surface.
And I think that was really like for me,
cause I've thought about it,
it's like the expression of gratitude overwhelmed me because I realized how
lucky I was.
Like,
you know,
you and any number of people can bring along whoever they want on the road with
them.
So like that for me was just like,
I couldn't believe how lucky I was to be able to travel,
could do real shows,
you know,
do real shows with like these really appreciative audiences and like you're
bringing me along and like,
I feel like,
uh,
like an equal,
it was overwhelming to me.
Do you know what,
what was overwhelming?
You are an equal,
we're all equal.
It's like we're all just like different parts of the road.
Yeah.
You know,
I could,
the road is the same road.
No,
it is,
but there's lessons like there's lessons from that,
you know,
like there's lessons that people are willing to burn themselves.
Yeah.
They gotta be willing to learn it themselves to tell you like you have to know
it encouraged,
you know,
it does just living through it encourages you to pass it along.
So that's kind of the coolest part is because like,
I mean I really tried to,
to mimic that.
You know,
I bring,
I brought a bunch of guys most recently,
Josh Potter is this really funny dude from buffalo and I brought him on most of
these dates and you know,
I,
I I hook up,
you know,
take care of his travel.
Like I've known you and it's like to the ice house.
Yeah.
And he's,
he's a,
he's a great,
he just moved here.
He's just good.
He's really funny.
Really,
really funny.
One of the only times I ever cried on a podcast was I'm listening to a podcast
where you were talking about your and I relationship.
It's one of the few times I ever cried like listening to a podcast.
I was like,
wow,
this is like heavy emotional.
We were talking about like me and you going on the road.
Like in the early days.
It was pretty fun.
I was amazing man.
It was your podcasts where we did the um,
uh,
buck hunter podcast is the beginning of that can cause the end.
We were talking,
you were talking about our relationship when you first started out.
It was good to go from open bikes to be able to see like,
like you said,
just like,
oh,
this is like a real crowd there.
It's here.
It's so big people,
some people never even get a taste to them and then you come back to that.
I always try to go back on Sunday night to the potluck.
Excuse me.
It was,
it was,
no,
it was Sunday then.
And then it was like to go back to dose of reality.
Right.
It sucks,
but I know I can do it now.
Yeah,
but you,
you all knew you.
Like everybody knows they kind of can do it.
That's why they're trying to do it.
But you need to,
someone who's ahead of you,
they're like holds a flashlight.
It's like,
come on,
take a look at this shit.
Come on.
We're all the same.
Keep going.
Be like when you took me to the left and limited
and I bombed in front of you for hours
like our,
he didn't know you from the time where I first met you to you having your own
comedy central show to having your own Netflix special.
Was this double special?
Those two hours I had to do to you.
Pretentious as fuck to 45 but it was just 40 fives have still half hour more
than anybody,
but it was,
it was still,
it was like,
wow,
that's weird when you can start your reality one way and then like just slowly
change over time
and that's what we,
it seems counterintuitive because you seem like you're trying to hold down the
competition.
The problem is if you hold down a competition,
you inevitably hold on yourself.
You don't,
you don't mean to.
Yeah.
The bar is set lower.
It's not just that.
It's like you're looking at the wrong way.
It's one of the reasons why I always took killers on the road.
Yeah,
that's a tough dude.
I used to always take Joey Diaz.
We took Dunkin,
we took Ari.
Like I always took murderers on the road.
Anybody following,
bringing electively,
bringing Joey is as always,
I it,
it was me for the longest time me than dos and rogue.
Great show.
And then it was in Austin.
Diaz goes,
Hey,
I'm going to go first today.
You're going to go last.
There are no second.
I mean,
I didn't know.
Now he's just,
he likes to go to sleep,
but then I was like,
am I being punished?
What did I do?
I don't do anything.
It's a terrible place to be following Joey in last.
It's not right.
So the thing is if you learn to embrace it,
yeah,
it's a good crowd.
I'm the number one Joey Diaz Fan in the world.
Other than like Joey Diaz is his wife and his daughter.
Yeah.
It's like there's like everybody else is like,
we're all,
if you might be the same,
but you definitely don't love him more than I do.
Right.
So for me it was like taking that on the road.
It's like I want to see him.
That's the only way you learn that doing stand up long enough.
If you embrace the person in front of you,
like you embrace it,
that this is like you enjoy it.
You can fall,
you can,
you can go back look,
and yet you can find,
okay.